[Music]
dr marlin farnsworth is a frailty
specialist
we met previously and her expertise is
in constant demand
valerie is 83 and lives alone
she fell out of bed but luckily could
still call for help i took a a bad fall
so i've got
my my problems are a walking problem
valerie's support will extend beyond her
hospital bed dr farnsworth calls it wrap
around care
dedicated support from a team of
specialists
most people want to be in their own
homes and most people want to have the
treatment and the care in their own
homes and if we think that's safe and we
think that's appropriate and in line
what matters most to valerie then that
is what we will support and we have a
team of doctors nurses therapists and
social care colleagues that can deliver
that treatment
discharging people is a huge problem for
the nhs
one in 10 patients can't be sent home
even though they are medically fit
luckily
valerie isn't one of them i mostly look
after myself though but i've also got
some very very good neighbors who will
do shopping for me and what have you so
in one sense i'm
i'm spoiled in that in that way
a few beds down from valerie is asha
khan
she has stage four cancer but the first
hospital she was taken to
couldn't find a bed for her
and asked epsom for help
this is the pressure on our health
service
and it's right across the nhs
there were more 999 calls last month
than any november on record
i need to be in police
that pressure will continue into
december
and with a threatened surge in omicron
cases
is why the government felt it had to
intervene
this time we're trying to progress with
our elective work
and we still have our winter pressures
coming in which i don't think we can
turn away like we did over the previous
two surges so
i'm actually more concerned this time if
we do absolutely nothing
all hospitals are trying to clear their
waiting lists
but this winter is likely to be the
hardest yet
the hospital is rightly very proud of
the integrated care it can offer its
patients like valerie but if there's a
surge in coveted missions well that puts
pressure on one part of the hospital and
that pressure soon spreads through the
system
valerie is going for her last scan
before going home
more patients here will benefit from
this support network
just as long as the covered storm
is kept at bay ashish joshi sky news at
epsom hospital